désolé pour le petit retard que nous
avons pris
donc nous poursuivons cet après-midi
chers collègues avec l'audition de
Monsieur Grégoire borst que nous
remercions beaucoup de sa présence
directeur du Laboratoire de psychologie
du développement et d'éducation de
l'enfant le labsidé au Centre national
de la recherche scientifique après vos
anecdotes à l'Université Paris-Sud et de
poste doctorat Harvard vous êtes
spécialisé en psychologie du
développement et en neurosciences
cognitive de l'éducation vous étudiez
notamment la manière dont le cerveau se
développe au cours du temps avec des
périodes selon l'âge de stabilisation au
contraire de reconfiguration étant alors
plus ou moins sensible à son
environnement ceci vous permet notamment
d'analyser les conséquences de
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux sur
nos fonctions cognitives en tenant
compte de cette complexité liée à l'âge
nous sommes donc curieux de bénéficier
de vos éclairages sur ce point notamment
au regard de l'usage qui est fait par
les enfants les adolescents de Tik Tok
c'est à dire un usage relativement
important puisqu'il se situerait autour
de 1h30 à 1h45 par jour ou plus de 10
heures par semaine pour les 4-18 ans à
ajouter au temps passé sur les autres
applications nous avons ici notamment
savoir si vous avez pu établir des
rapports de cause à effet entre une
exposition forte à des écrans et par
exemple un retard de développement
cognitif si oui pour quel âge vous menez
également un projet de recherche
novateur sur la capacité des adolescents
à identifier les fausses informations
auxquelles ils sont exposées sur les
réseaux sociaux et sur leur capacité à
résister à inhiber alors première
intuition en matière de traitement de
l'information et là encore nous sommes
nous sommes curieux d'en apprendre
davantage sur vos premiers résultats je
ne dois de vous rappeler que cette
audition est captée entre retransmises
en direct sur le site du Sénat avant de
vous laisser la parole pour votre exposé
luminaire je me dois de procéder au
formalités d'usage pour les commissions
d'enquête et vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage dans notre commission et
passible des peines préveuses articles
434 13 14 et 15 du code pénal et je vous
invite à prêter serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité en levant la
main droite et en disant je le jure
merci bien vous avez la parole une
quinzaine de minutes et puis je pense
que on aura un échange intéressant et
pas mal de questions à vous poser bon
déjà merci beaucoup pour cette
invitation je suis effectivement très
heureux de pouvoir vous parler de
l'adolescence avec beaucoup de
représentations qui peuvent être parfois
assez négatifs de cette période je vais
essayer de vous montrer aussi qu'il y a
des aspects très positifs à cette
période et quels sont les enjeux
finalement de cette exposition
aux écrans et à l'utilisation des
réseaux sociaux en ayant peut-être un
premier premier commentaire c'est que
finalement on sait peu de choses c'est
quand on se place du point de vue des
données qu'on a aujourd'hui de
disponibles on a peu de données de ce
point de vue là
et
ce qui crée une difficulté un peu
particulière vous allez voir que même
avec des données similaires les
interprétations de ces données sont très
différentes donc je vais essayer de
présenter ça très rapidement dans les 15
minutes puis évidemment vous vous
hésitez pas à me poser des questions
ensuite de façon plus générale sur Tik
Tok mais aussi sur d'autres réseaux
sociaux parce que je regardais ce matin
la littérature scientifique sur Tik Tok
finalement il y en a pas enfin ou très
très peu c'est à dire qu'on a très peu
de données aujourd'hui sur les
problématiques
de Tik Tok du point de vue de ce que ça
produit sur le cerveau en développement
et sur les compétences cognitives et
socio-émotionnelles de l'enfant et de
l'adolescent
ce qu'on essaye de faire dans mon
laboratoire qui est un laboratoire du
CNRS qui est la particularité d'être en
Sorbonne c'est le premier laboratoire
français psychologie scientifique qui a
été créé il y a 128 ans qui est toujours
resté un laboratoire de psychologie
scientifique aujourd'hui c'est 60
personnes qui essayent finalement de
comprendre le développement et les
apprentissages de l'enfant et de
l'adolescent dans le cadre d'un tissu
biologique en pleine maturation on a
depuis maintenant une vingtaine d'années
la capacité à pouvoir visualiser le
cerveau en développement d'essayer de
comprendre finalement la dynamique du
développement cognitif et
socio-émotionnelle au regard du
développement cérébral et ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui sur ce développement
cérébral c'est que finalement ce
développement cérébral il n'est pas je
dirais linéaire il s'opère de façon
dynamique non linéaire il s'opère de
façon assez synchrone à différents
rythmes dans les différentes régions
cérébrales
mental qui est juste derrière votre
front qui permet finalement tous les
toutes les mécanismes de régulation que
ce soit des mécanismes de régulation
cognitive comportementales impulsivité
et émotionnel et de cette asynchronie
entre un système limbique qui va finir
sa maturation très tôt et ce système
préfrontal qui finira sa maturation
beaucoup plus tard va créer cette
période de la vie qui est l'adolescence
et qui se définit par un certain nombre
de comportements associés que vous
connaissez peut-être pour ceux qui ont
la joie d'avoir des adolescents chez eux
et ou qui ne sont pas sorciers
et avec
et avec une période de maturation
cérébrale dont on ne parfois on oublie
un peu cette dimension là c'est que
cette période de maturation cérébrale
dure très longtemps elle dure jusqu'à
20-25 ans donc on reste adolescent d'une
certaine manière jusqu'à 25 ans du point
de vue de son développement cérébral et
donc ça en cascade plein de ça ouvre
plein de questions sur la question par
exemple de la responsabilité juridique
ça ouvre des questions sur la santé des
adolescents est-ce que c'est on est
adolescent quand on a 18 ans du point du
Cérébra en tout cas la réponse est non
on n'est pas adolescent on n'est pas
adulte jusque à 18 ans on est adulte
beaucoup plus tard
et la deuxième chose c'est qu'évidemment
cette ce développement cérébral il est
très façonné par l'environnement c'est à
dire quand on s'intéresse au
développement cérébral il faudrait pas
caricaturer ce que nous faisons en
neurosciences évidemment on s'intéresse
à l'environnement dans lequel se
développe l'enfant parce que puisque ce
cerveau se développe pendant plus de 20
à 25 ans Aix utero il est évidemment
très fortement influencé par
l'environnement dans lequel se développe
l'enfant on peut penser évidemment là à
l'environnement social dans lequel se
développe l'enfant on sait que dès 4
mois après la naissance cette maturation
du cerveau va différer en fonction de
l'environnement social de l'enfant parce
que cet environnement social va créer
des propriétés non optimales pour le
développement cérébral de l'enfant mais
évidemment donc l'exposition aux écrans
et à ce que font les enfants sur ces
écrans mais la dernière chose et je le
présente tout de suite c'est
qu'évidemment il y a des mécanismes de
compensation compensation je dirais de
d'environnement non optimaux pour la
maturation cérébrale très tôt dans la
vie ou plus tardivement du fait de
l'exposition si aux écrans par exemple
on a des mécanismes de neuroplasticité
dans le cerveau humain qui nous
permettent de compenser pour je dirais
des environnements qui ne sont pas
optimaux pour le développement cérébral
et ces mécanismes de neuroplasticité
c'est ces mécanismes qui permettent à ce
cerveau de se transformer donc
d'apprendre l'apprentissage est sous
tendu par des transports de notre
cerveau et ça c'est vrai pendant la
période de la maturation du cerveau de 0
à 25 ans mais c'est vrai en dehors de
ces périodes de maturation cérébrale à
tous les âges de la vie cette
neuroplasticité est en place et nous
permet d'acquérir de nouvelles
compétences on peut toujours apprendre
on peut toujours compenser à d'autres
périodes de la vie
et donc toutes ces nouvelles
connaissances sur le cerveau ça invite
aussi finalement à re questionner nos
modèles du développement cognitif et
socio-émotionnel on a été pendant très
longtemps influencé dans nos disciplines
par un modèle extrêmement prévalent qui
est le modèle 10 piagien qui était un
modèle finalement dans lequel on pensait
que l'intelligence de l'enfance se
développait par grand stade cumulatif de
l'intelligence et qu'en gros on passait
d'un bébé qui avait intelligent qui
avait essentiellement accès à une
intelligence on va dire relativement
concrète
sensorim motrice à un adolescent qui
avait enfin accès à une pensée
hypothétique audiéductive qui lui
permettait de penser de façon abstraite
et donc ça ça fait à peu près 60 ans
qu'on sait que c'est un modèle qui est
erroné de la façon dont il faut penser
le développement cognitif et socio
émotionnel de l'enfant et de
l'adolescent en fait très tôt le bébé a
déjà capable et déjà capable de penser
abstraite et finalement ça vous aura pas
non plus échappé que en tant qu'adulte
ça nous arrive encore de faire un
certain nombre de d'être sujet à
certains biais de raisonnement et bien
de prise de décision et donc finalement
le modèle il ne fonctionnait pas parce
qu'il pensait le développement cognitif
comme une marche en avant finalement
d'un bébé qui avait très peu de
compétences à un adulte qui avait toutes
les compétences et ça crée aussi
finalement une représentation du
développement cognitif qui considérait
qu'il y avait une énorme du
développement cognitif avec certains
stades de l'intelligence auxquels il
fallait passer à certains âges et
finalement c'est pas du tout ce qu'on
observe la norme du développement
cognitif et du Développement social
émotionnel celle hétérogénéité c'était
qu'en fait toutes les trajectoires
développementales sont différentes
toutes les trajectoires d'apprentissage
sont différentes et ça c'est la norme du
développement et donc évidemment ça pose
des contraintes quand on essaye de
comprendre l'effet de l'exposition aux
écrans sur des trajectoires
développementales et trajectoires
d'apprentissage qui sont différentes les
d'un individu à un autre
avec évidemment aussi sortir de cette
notion que c'est forcément quand on est
jeune que c'est négatif et forcément
moins négatif quand on est plus âgé
parce que c'est non conforme à ce qu'on
sait du développement cérébral et non
conforme de ce qu'on sait du
développement cognitif et
socio-émotionnel et finalement
progressivement alors dire qu'il y a que
de l'hétérogénéité ça pourrait dire que
on ne peut pas être identifier des
mécanismes qui produisent le changement
au cours du temps ou au cours des
apprentissages pas tout à fait que vous
êtes tous d'accord et toutes d'accord
que toutes les marées sont différentes
et pour autant c'est marrer sont toutes
régies par un même principe physique
c'est exactement pareil pour le
développement et les apprentissages
toutes les courbes sont différentes et
pour autant elles sont régies par des
mécanismes qui sont similaires et
notamment par ces mécanismes que vous
voyez en haut de cette diapositive qui
s'appelle système 3 troisième système de
pensée dans le cerveau humain qui relève
finalement de tous ces mécanismes de
régulation régulation émotionnelle
régulation cognitive régulation de nos
comportements et donc ce qu'on dit c'est
que finalement un des enjeux si ça c'est
un des mécanismes qui produit le
développement cognitif socio-émotionnel
et notre capacité réussi à maîtriser
notre impulsivité c'est probablement
là-dessus aussi qu'il faut penser
l'éducation finalement aux médias parce
que ça fait partie d'une certaine
manière en tout cas ça participe à nos
capacités de régulation face aux médias
et face à l'utilisation de ces médias
alors on sait on
propose effectivement que ces mécanismes
peuvent être des mécanismes fondamentaux
pour le développement cognitif
socio-émotionnel et pour la régulation
des comportements parce qu'on nous avons
des études effectivement longitudinales
qui montrent que quand on s'intéresse
aux prédicteur de la réussite éducatif
future donc ici ce qu'on essaye de
prédire c'est pas nécessairement la
réussite scolaire on n'est pas en train
de se demander comment on obtient des
bons résultats PISA mais comment on peut
une fois qu'on est sorti du système
éducatif avoir toutes les compétences
qui sont nécessaires pour être en bonne
santé pour avoir un bien-être qui soit
important pour qu'on ait une bonne
réussite professionnelle une bonne
réussite de vie quand on regarde quelles
sont ses indicateurs on retombe sur
cette ce type de compétences qui sont
des compétences de régulation notamment
notre capacité de maîtrise de
et donc quand on mesure sa capacité de
maîtrise de soi entre quatre et 11 ans
et quand on la compare par exemple aux
quotient intellectuel entre 91 ans et
par rapport au milieu social
socio-économique dans son issus ses
enfants ce qu'on voit c'est que même
quand on contrôle pour le caractère
prédictif du quotient intellectuel et du
milieu social d'origine de l'enfant ce
qui explique en grande partie votre
réussite éducative c'est vos capacités à
vous maîtriser c'est-à-dire votre
capacité de régulation de vos
comportements donc il y a un enjeu
effectivement à ce que ça puisse être un
des leviers finalement quand on pense
une éducation de façon globale à la
réussite éducative qui passe aussi par
l'utilisation des écrans et la
régulation face à l'utilisation des
écrans il y a ces mécanismes au cœur de
cette capacité là
c'est le nombre de d'enfants qui ont été
inclus dans l'étude depuis les années 70
donc c'est une étude qui a commencé en
1975 et qui a fini en 2004 2005 ce qui
vous montre aussi des problématiques qui
sont les nôtres aujourd'hui c'est que
l'énergie ouais c'est une corde en fait
qui est suivie sur 30 ans mais ce qui
montre bien effectivement la difficulté
qui est la nôtre aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
essaye d'avoir des réponses sur
l'utilisation par exemple des réseaux
sociaux est-ce que ça peut produire sur
le développement cognitif et
socio-émotionnel avec un temps de recul
qui est extrêmement faible c'est ce type
d'études qu'il faudrait que nous
puissions avoir pour avoir finalement
des données définitives par rapport à ce
que ça peut produire au cours du
développement
montrer rapidement c'est tout simplement
pour vous dire que c'est juste pour
illustrer ce que vous venez de dire sur
la capacité de de facteur prédictif là
sur la maîtrise de soi qui
conditionneuse vous pouvez juste nous
expliquer le coût du chamallow jamalo
c'est une façon d'évaluer cette maîtrise
de soi donc c'est pas ce qui a été
utilisé dans cette étude dans cette
étude c'est des observations
au sein de la cellule familiale des
observations à l'école des
questionnaires qui sont utilisés mais
généralement pour évaluer ses capacités
de maîtrise de soi on utilise une petite
tâche comportementale dans lequel on va
proposer à un enfant à marshmallow alors
ça peut être n'importe quel type de
friandise dont il est particulièrement
friand et on va lui dire tu peux manger
une marshmallow maintenant ou si tu
attends quand je reviens je t'en donne
un deuxième et à ce moment-là vous
sortez de la pièce l'enfant ne sait pas
combien de temps dure la tâche et vous
regardez le temps entre le moment où
vous lui avez donné la friandise et le
moment où il va finir par manger cette
friandise il y a un temps limité qui est
15 minutes mais ce qui est relativement
long quand vous avez trois ans
d'attendre 15 minutes devant une
friandise pour obtenir une deuxième
friandise puisque tout l'enjeu c'est
bien ça c'est d'arriver à évaluer votre
capacité à résister à la récompense
immédiate le plaisir associé à manger le
marshmallow tout de suite pour obtenir
une gratification différée plus
importante dans le futur de marche Malo
deux fois plus de plaisir et donc on
voit bien là pourquoi ça pourrait être
un prédicteur de la réussite éducative
future parce que finalement à partir du
moment où on se fixe des objectifs à
long terme qu'ils soient professionnels
qui soient personnel qui soit relatif à
notre santé c'est bien dans cette
activité que nous nous engageons
c'est-à-dire cette capacité finalement à
résister par exemple à boire un
troisième verre de vin pour éviter à
long terme les risques d'augmentation
par exemple du cancer c'est exactement
la même chose c'est la même activité
dans laquelle on s'engage
d'où le caractère prédictif de ce type
de compétences donc c'est ce qu'on
essaye de finalement d'étudier dans le
laboratoire que je dirige en combinant
des approches comportementales de
génétique des approches aussi de
contextualiser on essaye de comprendre
aussi qu'est-ce que ça produit dans une
salle de classe finalement l'ensemble de
ces compétences et quelles sont les
compétences qui permettent de prédire la
réussite éducative future des enfants la
particularité du laboratoire c'est
travailler à tous les âges de l'enfance
et de l'adolescence on commence dès le
bébé on va jusqu'à la fin de
l'adolescence c'est-à-dire jusqu'à 20-25
ans et ça c'est une particularité du
laboratoire et on travaille sur
beaucoup de domaines différents on
travaille et sur la problématique de
l'exposition à l'information et la
résistance aux fausses informations mais
on travaille aussi sur la lecture les
mathématiques sur la prise de décision
sur le raisonnement humain sur les
questions de créativité et on croise
ensemble de ces approches
méthodologiques pour essayer de
comprendre finalement quelles sont les
mécanismes qui produisent le
développement cognitif socio-émotionnel
la régulation émotionnelle chez les
adolescents je vais avancer un tout
petit peu vite une des choses sur
lesquelles on travaille beaucoup
laboratoire c'est la question des
inégalités éducatives comment les
combattre pas simplement comment les
observer donc certains nombre de projets
qu'on mène en ce moment au laboratoire
qui vise justement à essayer par exemple
de définir qu'est-ce qui explique des
difficultés en mathématiques et en
français dans les élèves qui sont
scolarisés dans les réseaux d'éducation
prioritaire et quel type de
d'intervention on peut penser en
fonction du profil cognitif de chacun de
ces élèves parce que on a des
difficultés en Mathé en français pour
des raisons très différentes on n'a pas
que des problématiques en mathématiques
parce qu'on a des problématiques par
exemple qui sont purement de cognition
numérique on peut avoir d'autres types
de problématiques dont ces
problématiques dont on a parlé ces
mécanismes transversaux impliqués dans
tout type d'apprentissage
et puis la dernière chose sur lequel on
travaille en ce moment beaucoup c'est un
projet de recherche qu'on mène en
partenariat avec Nathan et Ipsos qui
finalement vise dans son versant
fondamental à essayer de comprendre
quelle est la dynamique de la capacité à
discerner les vrais les fausses
informations chez les adolescents c'est
à notre connaissance la seule étude qui
existe au monde sur cette question sur
la question de cette capacité
intrinsèque cognitive des adolescents à
développer cette capacité à discerner
les vrais des fausses informations donc
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on leur présente
des postes qui peuvent être des posts
Instagram des posts Twitter des postes
Facebook alors on utilise plutôt
Instagram parce que c'est ce qu'ils
utilisent comme réseau social sur lequel
ils vont entre guillemets s'informer et
sinon c'est YouTube qu'ils utilisent en
priorité c'est leur premier réseau
d'informations ça reste YouTube
aujourd'hui et on leur présente une
information on leur demande sur une
échelle de 1 à 4 de déterminer à quel
point cette information est vraie ou
fausse s'il mette un ça veut dire qu'il
considère que l'information est fausse
6m4 il pense que l'information est vrai
et donc ensuite on peut moyenner pour
les informations qui sont vraies pour
des informations qui sont fausses et on
peut regarder s'il y a un delta en fait
entre les scores que les adolescents
attribuent à l'une ou l'autre des deux
catégories est-ce que vous voyez ici
c'est un graphique en 6e 5e 4e 3e et à
l'âge adulte ce que vous voyez c'est
qu'en 6e il y a pas de différence entre
les scores attribués pour les vrais et
les fausses informations pour des
adolescents de 6e ensuite il y a un
effet développemental progressif et une
capacité progressive qui se développe
donc ça c'est une étude transversale
c'est-à-dire qu'on a comparé des
sixièmes à des 5e à des quatrième année
troisième et en ce moment on mène deux
études longitudinales deux cohortes
qu'on suit dans différents pays
au Maroc en France mais aussi au Brésil
et en Inde sur lequel on va regarder la
dynamique en fait de cette capacité et
quelles sont les prédicteurs de cette
capacité à discerner les vrais des
fausses informations en pouvant
contrôler par un pour un certain nombre
finalement d'autres facteurs qui peut
être par exemple tant d'exposition le
temps passé sur les écrans le temps
passé sur les réseaux sociaux
et on a essayé en parallèle de se poser
la question de savoir qu'elle pouvait
être des pistes pédagogiques finalement
d'amélioration de ses capacités à
discerner les vrais des fausses
informations donc on mène ce type de
recherche dans des démarches de
recherche participative et
collaboratives dans lequel on compte je
vais y arriver on va co-créer ces
interventions avec des enseignants dans
un premier temps d'un combat co-créer la
situation d'évaluation va co-créer avec
eux les interventions que nous allons
mener dans les classes et puis ensuite
avec un deuxième groupe d'enseignants on
va ils vont collecter dans leur classe
une évaluation avant intervention une
évaluation après intervention donc on
est exactement dans le cadre d'une
démarche expérimentale classique qu'on
pourrait mener en laboratoire et ensuite
certaines classes vont suivre une
intervention et d'autres classes vont
suivre une autre intervention la seule
chose qui distingue les deux
informations les deux informations font
appel à ce qu'on utilise aujourd'hui
dans nos classes c'est-à-dire
l'éducation aux médias et l'information
on va prendre comment sourcer une
information comment finalement se poser
la question du type de documents
auxquels on est confronté le type de
source quel est le média qui a diffusé
cette information et puis la seule chose
qu'on fait dans l'autre intervention qui
va changer un peu c'est qu'avant de leur
présenter finalement ce qui relève du
sourcing de l'information on va leur
présenter des informations relatives
finalement alors capacité à comprendre
leur propre biais de penser quand ils
sont face à une information donc on leur
dit attention vous avez un cerveau qui a
des biais et parfois qui va pouvoir
penser qu'une information est vraie
alors même que c'est simplement parce
qu'elle est plus émotionnelle que
d'autres informations parce qu'elle a un
caractère plus surprenant et que ça ça
peut nous penser à penser qu'une
information est vraie et donc ensuite on
peut comparer les deux types
d'intervention est-ce qu'on observe pour
ce qui relève des infox c'est sur la
gauche de la diapositive ce qui est
attendu c'est que pour les infoges le
score qui est attribué avant
intervention en bleu soit plus
diminué après intervention en gris donc
c'est bien ce qu'on observe pour ce
qu'il relève de l'éducation médiane
l'information dans lequel on va
simplement avoir
un certain nombre d'interventions autour
des biais qui sont les nôtres quand on
essaye d'évaluer de l'information est-ce
que vous voyez sur la droite les deux
colonnes de droite en bleu et en gris
c'est l'éducation aux médias
l'information donc les deux vont dans le
bon sens mais le seul qui produit un
effet significatif c'est quand on
rajoute finalement à l'éducation aux
médias à l'information quelque chose qui
relève des biais de notre propre cerveau
face à l'information ça je dirais que
c'est le fait qu'on trouve pas forcément
de différence significative c'est pas
très problématique ce qui est beaucoup
plus problématique c'est ce qui se passe
sur la droite ce qui se passe sur la
droite c'est ce qui se passe pour les
véritables informations et là vous avez
l'hypothèse inverse c'est-à-dire que si
votre démarche ou votre intervention
fonctionne vous devriez avoir des scores
qui sont attribués aux vraies
informations qui vont augmenter entre
avant et après l'intervention c'est
exactement ce qu'on observe dans
l'intervention dans lequel on fait de
l'éducation médiale l'information plus
dans lequel on donne des informations
relatives au cerveau qui prend des
décisions face à ces informations par
contre quand on se borne à expliquer
comment on source l'information on a des
effets négatifs sur la la capacité à
discriner discriminer les informations
puisque on rend finalement les
adolescents sceptiques de toutes les
informations
très rapidement
oui sur la question des écrans je vais
je voulais on peut y revenir mais
simplement vous dire que la
particularité du cerveau adolescence et
qu'il est très focalisé sur les
récompenses il a il répond plus
fortement et notamment son système
limbique va répondre beaucoup plus
fortement à une récompense espérée et ça
explique aussi pourquoi les adolescents
s'engagent plus dans des situations de
prise de risque c'est parce que ils ont
tendance leur cerveau répond beaucoup
plus fortement à une récompense espérée
c'est ce que vous voyez dans cette
partie droite du de la diapositive on
peut en bleu vous avez des adolescents
et leur noyau à combat ce qui est une
des structures du système limbique et
notamment appliqué dans les
comportements d'addiction beaucoup plus
s'activer quand ils sont dans une
situation où ils peuvent espérer une
récompense
c'est ce qui explique aussi pourquoi ils
sont beaucoup plus orientés vers des
comportements effectivement répétitifs
dans lequel ils peuvent obtenir des
récompenses la deuxième chose c'est que
je vous ai parlé de cette tâche du
marshmallow et cette capacité à réguler
leur comportement et leur impulsivité et
ce qu'on voit c'est que tout au long de
l'adolescence ils ont plus de
difficultés à réguler leur impulsivité
donc c'est des périodes qui sont
propices finalement à s'engager dans des
dans un certain nombre de conduite
répétitives dans lequel ils peuvent
espérer des récompenses et c'est
d'autant plus vrai quand ils sont
contexte social quand ils sont en
contexte social ils sont encore plus
orientés vers les récompenses immédiates
c'est à dire vers le plaisir immédiat
par rapport à la capacité à différer
leur plaisir dans le long terme donc je
vais en venir aux écrans je vais sauter
tout ça parce que ça va être beaucoup
trop long simplement vous me posiez la
question de la causalité je vais vous
répondre que c'est particulièrement
difficile à établir
et que c'est bien ça la difficulté que
nous avons aujourd'hui c'est que la
plupart des études sont des études
corrélationnelles donc on ne sait pas si
c'est le temps d'écran qui produit des
effets sur le développement cognitif et
socio-émotionnel ou si c'est le
développement cognitif et
socio-émotionnel qui explique un temps
accru passer devant les écrans et c'est
très difficile pour l'instant de pouvoir
dissocier cela et d'autant plus qu'on
sait qu'il y a des variables latentes
c'est-à-dire d'autres variables qui
peuvent expliquer le lien entre le temps
passé devant les écrans et le
développement cognitif et
socio-émotionnel par exemple le statut
socio-économique des familles on sait
que les enfants qui vivent dans des
milieux sociaux économiques moins
favorisés passent plus de temps devant
les écrans du fait je dirais des
conditions de vie aussi de ces familles
et avec des familles monoparentales avec
des horaires des calés donc des risques
de passer plus de temps devant les
écrans et que le statut socio-économique
des familles explique aussi en partie
des différences de développement
cognitif et socio-émotionnel donc le
lien que vous pouvez observer il peut
être dû finalement à une troisième
variable qui est le statut
socio-économique
très rapidement si on regarde sur les
réseaux sociaux et le bien-être je
voulais simplement vous montrer ces deux
études elles sont intéressantes elles
sont tirées exactement de la même base
de données ces deux études tirées de la
même base de données qui est une énorme
base de données qui est disponible sur
des données américaines et anglaises ou
quand vous Colliez l'ensemble de ces
données vous avez accès à 500000 données
d'adolescents qui peuvent lier le temps
qu'il passe sur les réseaux sociaux et
leur bien-être et on peut évaluer
différentes dimensions du bien-être et
si vous regardez tout ça dans les deux
cas vous avez aussi au même constat il y
a un lien significatif entre les deux
mais qui est de l'ordre de 0,4% du
bien-être expliqué par le temps passé
devant les réseaux sociaux je répète
0,4%
. et dans un cas à gauche l'étude
conclue à dire que dans ces cas-là il
n'y a pas d'urgence d'une certaine
manière en terme de santé publique
l'autre étude qui observe exactement la
même chose vous dit qu'il y a donc une
urgence en termes de santé publique
donc c'est là où nous en sommes
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que sur la même
base de données vous avez deux
conclusions qui aboudissent finalement
statistiquement à la même conclusion
mais qui va ensuite en termes de
qu'est-ce que ça pose comme
problématique en termes de santé
publique arriver à des conclusions
radicalement différentes
ces deux études globalement ce qu'elle
recherche c'est est-ce qu'il existe un
lien entre le temps que vous passez sur
les réseaux sociaux enfin que les
adolescents passent sur les réseaux
sociaux pardon et le bien-être ressenti
par ces adolescents ces deux études vous
faites tourner des modèles statistiques
plus ou moins complexes mais globalement
ce qu'elle ce à quoi elles aboutissent
quel que soit ses études là c'est que
globalement le temps passé devant les
réseaux sociaux explique 0,4% du
bien-être des adolescents ou de la
variation du bien-être des adolescents
mais les deux concluent à la même chose
à gauche vous avez une chercheuse qui
disent ben si c'est 0,4 % il n'y a pas
de problématique de santé publique et
des chercheurs à droite qui vous disent
s'il y avait 0,4%, c'est donc un
problème de santé publique sa boîte je
conclue pas là dessus c'est à vous de
conclure je vous dis simplement que on
en est là aussi c'était même avec des
données qui sont basés objectivés et sur
les mêmes bases de données on a on
arrive à des
conclusions radicalement différentes
pour ce qui est relève des réseaux
sociaux et des difficultés
psychologiques si on regarde de 1990 à
2017 on n'a pas d'explosion
contrairement à ce qu'on peut entendre
je sais certains collectifs donc je
nommerai pas il y a pas d'explosion des
difficultés
relatives au bien-être des adolescents
quand on regarde un certain nombre de
modèles statistiques un peu complexe
sur des bases de données qui sont des
bases de données qui sont consolidées de
ce point de vue là c'est là qu'on est
sur des très grosses bases de données
donc entre 1990 et 2017 vous avez pas
d'explosion des difficultés
psychologiques rencontrées par les
adolescents du fait et encore une fois
ça ne serait qu'une corrélation du fait
de l'émergence de plus de numérique dans
leur vie quotidienne
c'est une corrélation globale et j'y
viens
vous avez entièrement raison donc une
des choses qu'on peut essayer de faire
aussi c'est de se poser la question
finalement de se dire qu'est-ce qui se
passe quand on regarde dans un
échantillon un peu plus restreint si
vous regardez au cours du temps sur
plusieurs semaines la variation du
bien-être des adolescents en fonction du
temps qu'il passe sur les réseaux
sociaux est-ce que là vous pouvez
trouver des associations vous trouvez
des associations c'est ce que montre ce
diagramme en bas de cette diapositive
mais ce que vous voyez c'est que on a
deux informations différentes quand on
regarde en intra-individuel c'est pour
un individu donné la variation du temps
qu'il passe sur l'écran et la variation
de son bien-être on a plutôt un effet de
plus il passe du temps sur les écrans
plus on a une diminution de son
bien-être c'est très relatif c'est en
quelques pour cent et que paradoxalement
pour ceux qui dépassent plus de 3 à 4
heures de temps passé ces réseaux
sociaux on a une augmentation du
bien-être donc c'est même pas linéaire
en termes de temps qu'on passe devant
ces écrans-là c'est-à-dire qu'on voit
qu'au sein quand on prend les extrêmes
de la distribution ici on a les 1% les
plus extrêmes de la distribution qui
passent le plus de temps sur les réseaux
sociaux eux pour chaque heure en plus
qu'il passe devant les réseaux sociaux
on a un bien-être associé qui augmente
et si vous regardez en inter individuel
j'essaye de rentrer dans toute la
complexité de ces données si vous
regardez entre les individus à ce moment
là quand vous êtes sur les 5% qui
consomment le plus
les 95% de la population excusez-moi qui
regarde des écrans chaque heure passait
entre 0 et 2 heures sur les écrans à
plus et plutôt associé à une
augmentation du bien-être
donc globalement on peut pas je dirais
d'une certaine manière conclure de façon
absolue dans un sens ou dans un autre
pour dire il y a des efforts extrêmement
négatifs de ces réseaux sociaux ou
extrêmement positif c'est ni l'un ni
l'autre c'est toute façon des effets
extrêmement faibles et là où je vous
rejoins qui vont dépendre en fait
fondamentalement des prédispositions
psychologiques de ces adolescents en
fait si on regarde l'adolescence comme
une population où les adolescents comme
une population homogène on se trompe
dans le constat que nous faisons parce
qu'effectivement ces réseaux sociaux
seront finalement des amplificateurs de
difficultés psychologiques préexistantes
chez l'adolescent et c'est ça la
complexité qu'on va avoir c'est à dire
que quand vous regardez par exemple ce
qui peut se passer sur un réseau social
en termes de comparaison sociale si vous
avez une bonne estime de vous-même et
que vous allez sur un réseau social et
que vous vous rentrez dans une situation
de comparaison sociale ça va plutôt
avoir un effet positif sur votre estime
de vous si vous venez avec une estime de
vous qui est négative ou mauvaise vous
allez sur un réseau social cette
comparaison sociale va aboutir à une
diminution de votre estime de soi
un effet de bulle c'est-à-dire plus on
passe du temps plus on s'enferme
globalement j'ai globalement terminé
c'était simplement pour vous montrer
cette étude là encore une fois toutes
les études je vous ai montré c'est des
études qui sont extrêmement récentes
c'est des études de 2019-2020 2021 2022
cette étude c'est une étude de 2020 qui
essaie de regarder finalement sur un
temps très long les rapports alors c'est
pas une corde c'est du transversal on va
prendre différents âges et on regarde
pour chacun de ces âges les associations
qui peuvent exister entre la
satisfaction dans la vie on n'est pas
ici dans le bien-être on est bien
d'accord c'est la satisfaction et vous
savez qu'en France parfois la
satisfaction est très mauvaise mais le
bien-être est bonne et bon ou l'inverse
donc ça ça veut pas forcément dire que
ça te dit quelque chose des difficultés
psychologique rencontrées par les
adolescents mais par contre si on
regarde la satisfaction dans la vie et
le temps passé sur les réseaux sociaux
on voit qu'en fonction des filles et des
garçons alors je suis désolé c'est un
tout petit peu genre et en rouge c'est
les filles en bleu c'est les garçons
mais entre 10 et 13 ans vous avez des
fenêtres développementales qui sont pas
tout à fait de les mêmes dans lequel il
faut avoir des points de vigilance c'est
un peu plus plutôt au début de
l'adolescence pour les filles parce
qu'elles rendent plutôt dans
l'adolescence qu'on a des liens négatifs
entre satisfaction de vie et temps passé
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est plutôt
entre 13 et 15 ans pour les garçons et
puis ensuite on a un autre pic vers 19
ans donc on voit que la complexité va
jusqu'à aussi aller regarder en fonction
du genre et en fonction du genre en
fonction de différentes périodes de
l'adolescence on va avoir des
associations différentes entre le
temps passé sur les écrans et la
certification dans la vie et j'en
termine sur n'importe
merci beaucoup monsieur professeur de
toutes ces
à la fois de cette démonstration et de
ses démonstration ou partir d'un côté de
cette non démonstration
moi je voulais vous alors je relève une
chose qui va être une limite à notre à
notre entretien c'est que vous avez
annoncé très humblement en début de
cette séance qu'il n'y a pour le moment
pratiquement pas de publication
scientifique sur Tik Tok en particulier
et nous notre commission d'enquête porte
sur TikTok en particulier mais
évidemment elle porte aussi sur sur
l'ensemble des réseaux sociaux
pour pour en venir à ce que à la
dernière partie de votre exposé
ma première question elle porte sur le
fait de savoir si c'est si le sujet
c'est celui du bien-être
parce que on peut aussi considérer que
si les réseaux sociaux rendent
quelqu'un qui passe 5 heures par jour
sur les réseaux sociaux et qui va
devenir neuneu il peut très bien avoir
un bien-être largement supérieur à celui
qui n'y passe que quelques secondes et
qui se posent des problèmes surtout au
moment de l'adolescence des problèmes de
de
personnel par conséquent
[Musique]
ma question porte également sur le plan
du développement cognitif et de
l'acquisition des connaissances
alors de ce point de vue là pour le
moment je reste sur ma faim j'ai
l'impression que j'ai mais c'est
évidemment qu'une impression et par
conséquent à toutes tous les biais
possibles bien entendu
on peut penser que quelqu'un qui passe
trois heures par jour et si la moyenne
est d'une heure et demie sur TikTok ça
veut dire qu'il y en a qui passent 3 ou
4 heures par jour
va
hypothéquer le qu'il passe des
acquisitions de connaissances plus
enfin différentes disons et
peut-être plus intellectuel plus
professionnel
et de ce point de vue est-ce que vous
avez est-ce que vous avez des mesures il
sent qu'il est au moins quelques mesures
qui paraissent enfin non pas de mesure
mais quelques décisions qui paraissent
aller dans ce sens puisque
TikTok en Chine a décidé de limiter à 40
enfin les Chinois ce n'est pas TikTok
les Chinois ont décidé d'y mettre à 40
minutes par jour le temps d'utilisation
de l'application ce qui n'était pas le
cas chez nous qui vient de commencer à
être le cas parce que devant l'ensemble
des accumulations de de
d'accusation TikTok propose une mesure
beaucoup moins forte puisque c'est quand
même limité à une heure mais c'est pas
vraiment limité au bout d'une heure on
interroge pour savoir si on veut
continuer donc de ce point et la
deuxième
[Musique]
la deuxième
comment dire intuition c'est que
apparemment dans la des principaux
acteurs de la Silicon Valley
soit limite considérablement soit
interdites à leurs enfants de se servir
des écrans donc ma question si vous
voulez c'est le bien-être c'est une
chose mais il y a aussi toute la
partie acquisition de connaissance
problème scolaire etc etc c'est ma
première question
ma deuxième question
[Musique]
et
le troisième point
c'est celui de la captologie c'est celui
de la technologie
dans le cadre de vos travaux de
recherche est-ce que vous avez
des informations ou les documents qui
attestent de l'existence de comportement
addictogènes spécifiques et tout le
monde dit l'algorithme est beaucoup plus
addictif est-ce que cet algorithme peut
beaucoup plus addictif parce qu'il est
beaucoup plus rapide notamment
introduit
un certain nombre de conséquences par
rapport aux autres réseaux sociaux
prendre ce que je sais pas surpris qu'on
soit un peu sur les mêmes questions les
uns les autres je propose de prendre la
question de notre collègue
merci beaucoup le président
effectivement mes questions rejoignaient
tout à fait celles de monsieur le
rapporteur et quand j'ai décidé de
j'avais décidé de poser la question tout
de suite je pensais à l'histoire de
l'addiction et du mal-être psychologique
dont on parle beaucoup chez les jeunes
et les adolescents en ce moment et alors
je ne sais pas comment c'est fondé etc
mais des pistes se creusent et
effectivement les pistes se creusent
autour de quoi on dit que les
adolescents sont beaucoup plus déprimés
depuis
la période covid et maintenant de plus
en plus de journalistes de scientifiques
et tout disent que non c'est lié à la
vêtement des réseaux sociaux et qu'on
est dans cette période là il vous
semblait contredire cette théorie
effectivement avec un manque de données
vous l'avez dit dès le départ votre
conclusion semblait plutôt rassurante
mais c'est un sujet j'ai des adolescents
et des jeunes adultes à la maison et
c'est un sujet de de d'inquiétude pour
moi bien évidemment et j'ai bien compris
tout ce que ça vous avez dit au sujet
la capacité d'apprentissage de la
maîtrise et moi je me demande toujours
aussi de quel est le degré du plaisir et
de l'apprentissage aussi quand un jeune
les réseaux sociaux il sera sur
peut-être en se disant qu'il va
apprendre des choses et que ça rentre
dans le contexte plus général de
l'éducation donc je voulais savoir quel
était vraiment la part de du plaisir et
de et du timing pur de la part de
l'apprentissage
je voulais savoir aussi on a pas parlé
de de problèmes de concentration qui
rentre dans les problèmes cognitifs à
mon avis c'est-à-dire que aussi d'un
problème de l'éducation sens pure et de
l'apprentissage il y a le problème de la
concentration et le modèle de Tik Tok de
ce point de vue là me semble
me semble parce que je ne suis pas
qualifiée pour le dire particulièrement
néfaste et enfin ma deuxième question
c'était de savoir si un fossé ne se
creusait pas de manière presque
rédhibitoire et en tout cas très
dangereuse entre l'adulte et l'enfant
puisque vous disiez vous-même que
souvent les enfants étaient autonomes
même sur les réseaux et plus le milieu
est défavorisé et puis il passe de et
les parents et l'éduc les parents dans
le sens éducateur
S sont évidemment indispensables dans le
dispositif et si le fait d'utiliser un
réseau comme Tik Tok ou un autre ne
creuse pas de manière définitive se
fausser entre l'adulte et l'enfant dans
un contexte d'éducation globale
[Musique]
la question que je vous posais est-ce
que vous avez communiqué avec
l'Éducation nationale sur vos résultats
parce que on sent bien dans ce que dans
ce que vous nous dites que on peut plus
qu'on sente plus se contenter
aujourd'hui du lire compter mais qu'il
faut rajouter un troisième savoir qui
devient totalement indispensable de
notre monde c'est l'esprit critique il
faut l'enseigner sans doute très très
tôt et sans doute beaucoup plus tôt que
ce qu'on imaginait jusqu'à présent donc
ce qui est une réflexion au sein de
l'éducation nationale parce qu'on parle
ici de la veille technologique de la
veille juridique par rapport aux
plateformes mais je pense que la veille
pédagogique c'est peut-être sans doute
aussi un des éléments forts que nous
pourrions mettre en oeuvre voilà je vous
remercie du coup je voulais vous laisser
poser les questions prioritairement je
rajoute juste une question ou un biais
en fait sous votre contrôle vous nous
expliquez que ce n'est pas le fait
d'aller sur des réseaux sociaux qui
frappent un gamin
et plus ou moins capable d'apprendre
c'est déjà la façon dont il est
structuré sur sa capacité de de comment
dire d'inhibition là ou de résistance
qui qui conditionne la façon dont il
appréhendra le réseau social mais une
fois que vous nous avez dit ça on ne
regarde plus comment dire la nature ou
le profil des gamins qui sont sur Tik
Tok une fois qu'ils y sont quelque soit
leur capacité de résistance est-ce que
vous pourriez nous préciser ce qui fait
que on peut en croyant aller y passer
cinq minutes y passer trois heures et
est-ce que il passait trois heures c'est
grave docteur
en fait c'est votre présentation nous
donne à penser que boivent finalement si
les gamins sont équipés pour se
reconcentrer par la suite c'est pas
grave mais qu'est-ce qui fait que ça
serait grave et qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on
a des enseignants qui nous expliquent
que ils discutent avec des gamins qui au
début de l'année paraissent pas trop mal
équipé et qui leur explique au bout d'un
moment qu'à 23 heures ou 1h du mat ils
sont sur Youtube Tik Tok YouTube ou
autre qui est peu de données sur Tik Tok
du fait de la de la du nombre d'abonnés
récents d'une chose mais le problème
reste le même quoi
juste pour compliquer j'aurais bien
voulu avoir votre avis sur le fait que
une application comme Tik Tok puisse
amener des mineurs
ne plus faire preuve de discernement au
point que lors de défi lancé sur ce
réseau social
certains sont amenés à commettre des
gestes
comment dire on a parlé d'abruti d'abord
oui
d'abrutissant comme de mettre un animal
dans un sèche-linge
c'est ce qui s'est passé c'est ce qui
s'est passé récemment voilà pour gagner
un défi en ligne
vous aviez une question complémentaire
j'aime beaucoup je suis désolée de
reprendre la parole mais dans
l'utilisation d'un réseau comme Tik Tok
pendant deux ou trois heures c'est
peut-être une question qui est plus
sociologique d'ailleurs mais dans la vie
d'un adolescent ce temps-là a été pris
sur quel autre temps est-ce que c'est le
temps d'aller l'apprentissage scolaire
est-ce que c'est le temps de la vie en
famille est-ce que c'est le temps du
loisir avec les amis c'est ça aussi que
et Monsieur gatelin très rapidement
dans le même sens mais en d'autres
termes on est souvent dans une
opposition entre conformité et
transgression on se demande si sur ce
type de réseau qui font des défis on
n'est pas dans la conformité de la
transgression est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui est particulier à l'âge
adolescent et prêt à délaissant
pour pas qu'il y ait de frustration le
lapsidée n'est pas très loin donc si un
jour vous voulez organiser un café pour
décortiquer tout ça le labo n'est pas
loin
vous avez vous êtes toutes et tous les
bienvenus
non non mais parce que je crois que
Monsieur bourse avait été auditionné par
par la Commission sur la pornographie
je vais je vais essayer de répondre sur
les différents points alors c'est vrai
que j'ai très peu abordé la question
cognitive
je l'ai très peu abordé parce que les
données sont encore moins convaincantes
de ce point là c'est à dire que
j'entends bien qu'il y a une crainte je
dirais légitime de ce point de vue là
pour autant pour ce qui relève avec
toute la limite qu'il peut y avoir à
s'intéresser au temps d'écran ou au
temps passé sur les réseaux sociaux
on n'a pas de lien
avéré systématique négatif avec le
développement cognitif de l'enfant on va
dire au-delà de trois quatre ans
c'est-à-dire qu'en dessous de 3-4 ans il
y a des données qui semblent être
cohérentes et convergentes qui semble
suggérer que ça entraîne non pas des
troubles mais des retards sur
l'acquisition du langage de la
reconnaissance des émotions parfois de
certains types de motricité par exemple
la motricité fine qui ne sont pas des
retards qui sont irrattrapables ensuite
mais qui peuvent effectivement expliquer
le temps passé dans des moments où
notamment nous devrions être être humain
en construction en interaction avec nos
parents donc ça c'est la première chose
plus tard il y a très peu de données qui
semblent suggérer en tout cas qu'on a un
effondrement massif du développement
cognitif de l'enfant et de l'adolescent
du fait du temps qu'il passe devant les
écrans si ce n'est que et je vais tout
de suite je dirais modérer ce que je
vous dis et ça reviendra sur d'autres
questions que vous m'avez posées si ce
n'est qu'on sait qu'effectivement une
des données sur lesquelles on a donné
qui sont extrêmement convergentes c'est
que ce temps passé devant les écrans et
sur les réseaux sociaux notamment ceux
sur lequel on a du mal à déterminer le
temps qu'on nous y passons parce que
c'est vrai pour eux c'est vrai aussi
pour nous et que de toute façon dans
toutes ces études à partir du moment où
on est dans du déclaratif nous savons
bien que nous sous-évalons le temps que
les adolescents passent sur ces études
là on sait que globalement la
corrélation entre le temps passé
réellement sur les écrans et le temps
déclarer c'est de l'ordre de 20%. c'est
non c'est même moins que ça c'est point
20 donc c'est entre l'indicateur qui va
être 0,1 c'est très peu en fait
c'est-à-dire que il y a pas en fait le
déclaratif est assez problématique de ce
point là on sait que ça a un effet sur
la qualité du sommeil des adolescents
donc c'est un effet sur la qualité du
sommeil des adolescents et des adultes
sauf que l'adolescence c'est une période
de dans lequel on a je dirais une
convergence de problématiques une
problématique qui fait que du fait même
de la structure à son de nos sociétés
ils sont en déficit de sommeil beaucoup
plus important qu'un n'importe quel
autre période de la vie parce que leur
cycle de sommeil est en train de se
décaler de plus de deux heures que
l'institution n'a pas modifié son temps
scolaire c'est-à-dire qu'il n'a pas
alors que on sait tous que c'est si vous
voulez quelque chose qui coûte peu cher
à l'institution et qui produit des
effets massifs sur les apprentissages
décaler deux heures la première heure de
cours au collège vous allez voir c'est
miraculeux c'est à dire que vous allez
respecter enfin le temps finalement
physiologique de l'adolescent parce que
de toute façon il va se coucher à 11
heures il s'est décalé deux heures parce
que son pic de mélatonine était en train
de se décaler de deux heures donc si
vous y rajoutez à ça l'écran vous allez
avoir d'un décalage encore plus
important et donc ça va jouer sur la
qualité du du sommeil et comme le
sommeil à deux finalement joue sur deux
aspects extrêmement importants pour les
apprentissages qui sont la
neuroplasticité c'est à dire la capacité
du cerveau à se transformer au cours des
apprentissages et qu'elle joue également
sur les capacités de mémorisation on
voit bien comment ça peut avoir des
répercussions sur les apprentissages
mais il faut bien comprendre que c'est
pas en soi l'écran ou le réseau social
et sa structuration même qui produit cet
effet c'est que ça produit un effet sur
le sommeil et cet effet sur le sommeil a
des effets en cascade sur les
apprentissages donc c'est pas un effet
direct mais c'est un effet indirect et
donc ça veut dire que en termes de
politique
l'idée c'est ou en tout cas éducatif
c'est plutôt de se dire comment on fait
une éducation au sommeil et il y a des
dispositifs qui semblent fonctionner de
ce point là pour améliorer la qualité du
sommeil chez les adolescents
sur l'aspect cognitif alors oui bien sûr
ça prend du temps sur autre chose ça on
est tous d'accord c'est à si vous passez
énormément de temps sur les écrans c'est
du temps que vous ne faites pas à faire
autre chose mais la difficulté c'est
qu'est-ce que vous faites réellement sur
votre écran
quelle activité quel contenu auquel vous
êtes explosé ça ne reste qu'un média
donc la difficulté aussi c'est est-ce
que vous êtes dans une situation de
création Tik Tok c'est aussi de la
création alors je on peut le regarder
avec notre œil d'adulte on considérant
que c'est totalement futile mais pour
autant il crée quand même sur Tik Tok
les adolescents donc ils sont pas
engagés que dans une espèce de
visionnage passif de vidéos sur Tik Tok
ils font aussi de la création et donc
c'est très différent si vous êtes engagé
dans de la création de contenu que quand
vous êtes simplement passif de en
observation de certaines vidéos sur Tik
Tok donc là dessus on n'a pas donné en
fait parce que c'est très difficile de
pouvoir analyser cette granularité là
d'usage de ces écrans donc ça c'est pour
le domaine cognit pour le domaine de
cette loi oui je j'en ai entendu parler
est-ce que c'est une bonne chose alors
je vais faire deux réponses la première
chose c'est que
c'est une bonne chose mais déjà
peut-être faudrait-il que nous nous
assurions que les enfants n'est pas de
compte et n'aillent pas sur TikTok avant
13 ans je rappelle que c'est interdit
d'aller sur TikTok avant 13 ans donc on
a déjà là un premier problème c'est
comment on s'assure que les adolescents
alors même qu'on a une limite d'âge
quand même d'utilisation de ces réseaux
sociaux sont et j'étais encore il y a
quelques semaines dans un collège en 6e
je leur posais la question de savoir qui
avait un compte sur un réseau social et
ils avaient tous sans exception un
compte sur les réseaux sociaux et quand
je leur disais mais vous savez
pertinemment que c'est interdit oui mais
il suffit de mettre une autre date de
naissance donc là on est aussi dans un
vrai problème c'est à dire qu'à un
moment et on en revient à la
problématique des parents et de
l'éducation des parents autour de ces
questions-là si on veut pouvoir
accompagner l'usage de ces réseaux
sociaux il va falloir aussi penser une
forme de coéducation sur ces questions
là c'est absolument pas normal qu'on
laisse des enfants être utilisé ce type
de réseaux sociaux parce que la question
qu'on n'a pas abordé c'est la question
aussi de l'exposition du contenu non
approprié pour ses enfants et c'est bien
là aussi un des problèmes c'est-à-dire
que ils utilisent ces réseaux sociaux
ils sont exposés à du contenu d'un
approprié et ça ça peut avoir
effectivement des conséquences notamment
sur leur bien-être alors que s'ils sont
accompagnés par des parents on voit bien
que c'est aussi une façon de pouvoir
finalement
réévaluer ce à quoi ils ont été exposés
donc je dirais que sur cette
problématique du de repousser la
majorité numérique ça va dans le bon
sens mais dans ces cas-là comment on
fait pour s'assurer qu'avant 15 ans il
n'aille pas sur ses réseaux sociaux
c'est accès si on repousse de deux ans
mais sans avoir de garantie qu'il n'y
aille pas ça ne va rien changer c'est
bien c'est bien le problème donc je
pense qu'il y a un vrai par contre là
une responsabilité de ces réseaux
sociaux et de ses plateformes mais je
inclus aussi Youtube je veux dire les
discussions qu'on a eues à l'arcom avec
Youtube de ce point de vue là était
quand même surréaliste c'est-à-dire
qu'on leur disait mais pourquoi vous ne
mettez pas l'ensemble du contenu
jeunesse sur Youtube
jeunesse kids et on nous a répondu mais
parce qu'il y a des adultes qui aiment
bien regarder du contenu jeunesse mais
je veux dire la responsabilité elle est
bien la responsabilité je veux dire de
respecter le droit des enfants qui
soient pas exposé à du contenu non donc
voilà il y a quand même là je pense des
dispositions à prendre peut-être avant
de se poser la question de repousser la
majorité à 15 ans la dernière chose
c'était la question de l'addiction alors
la réponse elle est complexe
il n'y a pas d'addiction du même ordre
pour l'instant en tout cas en l'état de
nos connaissances il n'y a pas
d'addiction du même ordre que celle
engendrée par de la prise de substances
psychoactives ou de la consommation
d'alcool parce qu'on nous n'avons pas
pour l'instant en tout cas de données
qui semble suggérer une modification par
exemple de la concentration de certains
récepteurs à la dopamine qui est un des
neurotransmetteurs qui est impliqué dans
l'addiction et dans la recherche du
plaisir une fois que je vous ai dit ça
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y a pas
d'addiction et c'est très décrié
comportemental c'est-à-dire des
comportements d'ordre addictifs sur ces
réseaux là mais il faut dissocier quand
même ce qui relève d'une addiction
de l'ordre de celle qu'on peut observer
dans une addiction à la drogue et à
l'alcool les mettrai ensemble parce que
ce que ça produit sur un cerveau
adolescence est strictement la même
chose pour autant ça veut pas dire qu'il
y a pas d'utilisation excessive de ce
type de
de réseaux sociaux mais ça reste très
débattu
donc sur les trois questions que vous
m'avez posées voilà les réponses que je
pouvais vous donner la question du covid
et la question de la du débat qu'il y
aurait entre savoir si ce qui est
produit en termes de santé mentale sur
les adolescents relèvent finalement
d'une problématique qui relèverait
plutôt soit d'une utilisation excessive
des réseaux sociaux soit du temps de la
covid la réponse elle est très difficile
à trancher parce que il y a une
covariation de plus de temps passé
devant les écrans pendant la période de
la coïd et effectivement d'une
dégradation globale de la santé mentale
des adolescents post covid
quand on regarde le ce que produit le
temps passé sur les écrans et
l'association avec le bien-être ressenti
des adolescents et donc les difficultés
qui peuvent avoir en termes de symptômes
dépressif si c'est 0,4 % qui est
expliqué par le temps passé devant les
écrans
on peut se dire que quand on regarde par
son par contre le stress chronique
auquel on est exposé est-ce que ça peut
produire sur l'anxiété et donc sur les
risques des dépressions je dirais que le
la jauge va plutôt sur le fait que la
covid a été quand même une période très
particulière dans laquelle je rappelle
qu'il y a eu un discours très
particulier aussi adressé aux
adolescents le discours adressé aux
adolescents il était quand même
particulièrement anxiogène c'est vos
comportements vont entraîner un risque
accru pour vos familles qu'ils attrapent
le covid et vous enfin je caricature
mais on n'était pas très loin de vous
allez être responsable de la mort de vos
grands-parents
et quand ils sont revenus dans l'école
et quand et quand ils sont revenus dans
l'école on n'avait pas forcément préparé
le retour dans l'institution parce qu'on
manque de psychologue de l'éducation
nationale et que donc il n'y a pas pu y
avoir au moment où ils sont revenus dans
les écoles une discussion autour de
cette période quand même très
particulière qu'ils ont vécu dans pour
un cerveau qui est encore une fois très
particulier parce que ce qu'il recherche
à l'adolescence et c'est difficile pour
nous parents parfois de l'accepter c'est
on passe d'un lien d'attachement qu'il
se fait au sein de la cellule familiale
un lien d'attachement qui se fait au
sein d'un groupe social extérieur à la
cellule familiale donc ils ont besoin
des interactions sociales avec les
autres et ces réseaux sociaux ils n'ont
pas que des aspects négatifs c'est à
dire que ils ont permis pendant le temps
de fermeture des écoles aux adolescents
de maintenir du lien social
parce qu'il les utilise quand même pour
maintenir du lien social de TikTok c'est
un peu différent mais en tout cas sur
les autres réseaux sociaux il les
utilise et quand même essentiellement
pour maintenir du lien social avec leur
père sur la question de l'attention
il faut dissocier deux choses ce qui est
de l'ordre de est-ce que les capacités
attentionnelles des adolescents
aujourd'hui et des enfants s'est
effondré la réponse est non ils ont les
mêmes capacités à tententionner si vous
utilisez des tests classiques qu'on
utilisait il y a 20 30 ans pour évaluer
les capacités attentionnelles des
enfants ils ont les mêmes capacités
attentionnelles mais ils sont dans un
monde qui a radicalement changé
ces deux choses différentes ils sont
dans un monde dans lequel leur capacité
à attentionnelles leurs ressources
attentionnelles sont en permanence
captées par de multiples sites par de
multiples terminaux le portable d'un
côté la télévision de l'autre plus au
d'autres types d'interférences qui
peuvent avoir dans l'environnement donc
oui distribue beaucoup plus que nous
leurs ressources attentionnelles et donc
ce qui crée effectivement des
difficultés de concentration mais ces
deux choses différentes ils ont tout à
fait la capacité de se concentrer ils
ont tout à fait la capacité d'engager
les ressources artelles et pour ceux qui
jouent beaucoup aux jeux vidéos ils
développent même sans doute des
meilleurs ressources attentionnelles et
une meilleure capacité attentionnelle
que nous parce qu'on sait
qu'effectivement les jeux les jeux vidéo
ça a des conséquences positives sur le
développement des ressources
attentionnelles ce qu'on aime pas c'est
les jeux de tir à la première personne
très bon pour développer les capacités
attentionnelles des enfants et des
adolescents
avec avec des avec des effets qui se
maintiennent jusqu'à 2 ans après l'arrêt
de l'utilisation des jeux vidéo on
aimerait ça pour tous les apprentissages
je veux dire des effets à deux ans après
l'arrêt de l'intervention c'est
absolument formidable ça veut pas dire
que ça règle qu'il faut dire à tous les
adolescents maintenant de jouer aux jeux
vidéo c'est pas du tout en train de ce
que ce que je suis en train de dire et
donc ça joue sur les capacités de
concentration il faut bien comprendre
que les capacités de concentration c'est
aussi un problème de motivation c'est de
la motivation intrinsèque des
adolescents à s'engager dans une
situation d'apprentissage on en
reviendra à ce moment-là à la notion de
plaisir dans le cadre d'apprentissage
qui quand vous le regardez avec le
prisme peut-être d'un regard
d'adolescent aujourd'hui se rend bien
compte quand même qu'il y a un décalage
de plus en plus fort entre ce qu'on lui
apprend à l'école et la réalité dans
laquelle il vit
je veux dire on n'a jamais eu de de
dissociation aussi forte entre nos
systèmes éducatifs et la réalité du
quotidien de ces adolescents et ne
croyez pas qu'il ne soit pas en mesure
d'analyser ça de façon extrêmement
précise il voit bien qu'il hiatus quand
même entre ce qu'on leur demande de
faire aujourd'hui à l'école dans un
monde dans lequel je rappelle qu'on a
toutes et tous à disposition toute la
connaissance qui a été créée dans
l'humanité en 15 millisecondes et quand
on y va leur dire il faut apprendre des
connaissances
je dis pas qu'il faut pas prendre de
connaissances je dis que si on ne passe
pas par une nécessité par une
explication de pourquoi il faut
apprendre des connaissances on se
retrouve dans une situation très
complexe donc quand on parle de
l'éducation médias c'est jusque là qu'il
faut aller aujourd'hui on a besoin de
connaissances pourquoi parce que en fait
on a besoin de connaissance pour pouvoir
juger de l'information auquel on est
exposé mais c'est pas du tout la même
chose que ce qu'on disait avant on n'a
même pas besoin de l'expliquer un élève
il était là il respectait d'une certaine
manière la situation
d'interaction de tutelle entre un
enseignant et un élève qui pouvait de
toute façon acquérir des connaissances
uniquement par le savoir qui lui était
prodigué par l'enseignant c'est terminé
elle est là cette révolution elle a eu
lieu et donc je pense que quand on parle
de l'attention et de la concentration
souvent qu'on capte c'est ça c'est ce
manque de motivation finalement des
élèves à s'engager dans la situation
d'apprentissage et on voit bien à partir
du moment où ils sont intéressés je
reprends l'exemple des jeux vidéo quel
persévérance ils ont dans un jeu vidéo
c'est incroyable le temps qu'il passe
pour passer un nouveau niveau dans un
jeu vidéo on aimerait bien qu'ils aient
le même type de persévérance quand ils
sont face à un problématique pas un
problème de mathématiques
et donc il faut rendre la situation
d'apprentissage je dirais
intrinsèquement motivante pour lui
et la question du fossé entre l'adulte
et l'enfant je pense que vous mettez le
point sur quelque chose d'absolument
fondamental c'est à dire qu'on sait
qu'effectivement
en tout cas chez les plus jeunes si vous
voulez avoir des effets potentiellement
positifs parfois aussi de l'utilisation
des écrans vous avez besoin d'avoir une
utilisation avec les parents de ses
enfants et avec les parents pardon de
ces écrans et donc cette notion qu'on ne
peut pas laisser les enfants seuls
devant les écrans elle est absolument
fondamentale et en même temps il y a une
réalité sociologique quotidienne qui est
difficile et qui renvoie effectivement à
des différences aussi de milieux social
d'origine dans lequel quand vous êtes
dans une famille monoparentale c'est
beaucoup plus difficile d'être tout le
temps en co-utilisation des écrans mais
donc il y a aussi cette notion là pour
éviter ce fossé il faut que les parents
s'intéressent à ce que font leurs
adolescents sur ces réseaux sociaux
parce que c'est aussi un moyen d'une
certaine manière de pouvoir compenser
certaines dérives vous parliez de cette
dérive de finalement par des mécanismes
oui oui par des mécanismes finalement de
conformisme social parce que c'est bien
de se cela dont on parle cette
problématique de discernement c'est
aussi une problématique de l'adolescence
on sait qu'à l'adolescence les
adolescents sont beaucoup plus sujet au
conformisme social c'est-à-dire qu'ils
ont tendance à prendre la position qui
est dominante dans le groupe et
effectivement sur un réseau social c'est
tout à fait ce qui peut se passer mais
exactement ce qui se passe dans la
réalité je veux dire de tout temps des
adolescents ont martyrisé des animaux
sauf que maintenant c'est médiatisé non
mais enfin je veux dire je ne dis pas ça
comme une perspective
c'est d'une certaine manière se
conformer en tout cas à une position
transgressive dominante à un moment là
qui est effectivement d'aller tester un
certain nombre de limites aussi parce
que effectivement c'est une encore une
fois ce sont des limites imposées par
les adultes et que au moment de
l'adolescence effectivement on cherche
ce lien social on cherche cette
récompense sociale il faut bien
comprendre quand on dit que le cerveau
adolescent est orienté vers la
récompense oui mais pas n'importe quel
type de récompense il recherche des
récompenses sociales ils recherchent un
statut social dans son groupe
d'appartenance donc d'où les dérives
qu'on peut observer mais des rives qu'on
observe aussi dans la vie réelle on les
voit simplement un peu moins
oui mais les défis les défis c'est le
quotidien d'un adolescent j'ai le
l'adolescent dans sa vie quotidienne est
dans une situation de défi permanente
parce que effectivement il est en
compétition avec les autres pour un
statut dans un groupe social ça
n'empêche pas d'avoir des situations de
coopération contrairement à ce que je
peux entendre parfois on dit que les
adolescents sont particulièrement
individualistes c'est absolument pas
vrai je veux dire les adolescents ils
sont extrêmement prosociaux on voit bien
d'ailleurs qui s'orientent vers des
grandes causes qui sont particulièrement
sensibles
aux injustices il faut quand même
prendre en compte que un cerveau
adolescent face à une injustice ce qui
s'active dans son cerveau c'est toutes
les zones qui sont impliquées dans la
douleur physique c'est une douleur
physique pour lui et donc ça explique
aussi les réactions parfois extrêmement
excessives dans des cas d'injustice ou
en tout cas dans la justice ressenti
on s'arrête et ben j'ai non mais je
crois que c'est quasiment tout répondu à
tous les questions
est-ce que le rapporteur une dernière
question
il me semble que j'avais j'avais noté
deux autres choses
les suivants la question de pourquoi on
passe autant de temps sur les réseaux
sociaux la Légion est effectivement la
question de l'évaluation du temps que
nous passons notamment dans des
activités qui comme elles sont très
courtes et avec des boucles de
récompense qui sont assez rapides
c'est-à-dire que typiquement Tic-Toc ce
qu'il produit c'est de nous présenter
des vidéos qui sont les plus proches de
celles qu'on aimerait voir et donc ça
nous ça crée une boucle finalement de
récompense relativement courte des
boucles de récompense on en a dans
toutes les activités que nous menons
dans notre vie quotidienne à partir du
moment où on va manger une bonne un bon
gâteau dans une pâtisserie on a notre
réseau de la récompense qui s'active
pour autant ce que font ces réseaux
sociaux c'est qu'il joue sur des boucles
de récompense extrêmement rapides et
donc qui entraîne une motivation à
persévérer sur ce réseau social là et
c'est pour ça effectivement qu'on a
tendance à avoir un temps une mauvaise
estimation du temps que nous y passons
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin de
contrôler effectivement sur le temps
qu'on y passe ça peut être 40 minutes
moi je suis toujours un peu sceptique
sur l'idée que ce contrôle doit venir de
l'extérieur et je crois que si on pose
pense une éducation elle doit se penser
sur une progressivité dans un premier
temps je pense qu'effectivement il faut
que les parents via le contrôle parental
et je sais que c'était en discussion
maintenant sur tout nouveauté terminale
numérique à partir du moment où on
l'allumera il y aura la possibilité de
définir un contrôle parental je pense
que c'est une bonne chose et que dans un
premier temps du développement de
l'enfant il a besoin d'avoir un contrôle
de l'extérieur mais le véritable enjeu
c'est qu'il arrive à s'auto réguler sur
son sur ses
usages parce qu'on pourra pas toujours
être derrière lui c'est si ça le
problème c'est qu'à un moment ils sont
seuls
donc si on n'arrive pas à les
responsabiliser face à ça on va se
retrouver dans une situation difficile
et cette fois-ci je crois que j'ai fini
merci beaucoup
on est on est un peu rassuré à la fin
parce que vous avez commencé par le fait
que c'est la capacité quel est le terme
est de résistance ou de ou d'inhibition
qui comment dire qui fixe quelle sera la
capacité d'apprentissage pour plus tard
et on termine par le fait que on est
bien sur des algorithmes TikTok ou un
autre mais en l'occurrence d'autres
spécialistes ergoniques nous ont
expliqué pourquoi suite Tik Tok était
plus addictif qui fait que on nourrit un
circuit de la récompense gratuite et un
peu bébête enfin ou un peu facile et que
donc ça pose un problème sur sa capacité
globale appréhender le monde voilà mais
l'objectivation statistique c'était
l'apport de ça et la deuxième chose
peut-être la dernière chose sur lequel
je voulais simplement conclure c'est de
dire que si on veut réellement apporter
des réponses éducatives à cette question
là parce qu'elle se pose je veux dire on
est dans un nouveau monde des nouveaux
outils des nouveaux usages et donc il y
a évidemment une éducation qui se pose
je pense que vous l'avez posé en termes
de pensée critique mais de façon
beaucoup plus globale il y a aussi
finalement enseigner à la façon dont on
prend des choix on a finalement très
très peu de connaissances sur notre
propre psychologie sur le fonctionnement
de notre cerveau quand même voir
qu'aujourd'hui dans notre système
éducatif la première fois on entend
parler du cerveau c'est en 4e
je veux dire ce qu'on utilise tous les
jours dans une salle de classe pour
apprendre et dans notre vie quotidienne
c'est notre cerveau il y a un défaut de
connaissance sur le cerveau qui est
absolument gigantesque dans une
situation quand même un peu paradoxale
ou je dirais le triangle de la situation
éducative l'élève le parent ou le
responsable légal de l'enfant et
l'enseignant n'ont aucune connaissance
sur leur cerveau respectif
et on espère que de là va émerger de
l'apprentissage je pense que on peut
trouver des meilleures situations
effectivement pour améliorer
l'apprentissage des élèves donc il faut
leur parler d'un cerveau très tôt et
comment il fonctionne face à ces outils
là
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup merci